we've seen graphs involving boys and
girls and connections between them in
the context of our sexual demographics
calculation and study a similar problem
comes up in terms of what it calls
stable matching which is again the issue
of matching up boys and girls in a
special way according to some
constraints it turns out to have a lot
of applications which we'll discuss
towards the end let's just look at what
the problem is the setup is that there's
some number of boys in this case five
one through five and an equal number of
girls labeled a through e and each of
the boys has a ranking of the girls
different rankings because different
boys have different preferences and
likewise the girls have rankings of the
boys different girls have different
preferences so here girl a likes boy
three best and boy five second best and
boy one likes girls C best and girl
'they least so the problem basically is
that we want to get all the boys married
to all the girls we want to form five
monogamous bisexual marriages a boy and
a girl and we'd like in some vague way
to acknowledge these preferences and
satisfy as many as we can
I'll be more specific about that in a
minute let's just play with that idea of
trying to accommodate people's
preferences so one way to do it is let's
just decide will will favor the boys
this time let's try a greedy strategy
than the boys let's just look at the boy
preferences and we really strategy
because I'm gonna try to give each boy
the best possible choice that he can
make so I'm gonna start off by deciding
that let's let boy one have his first
choice girl's safe
I'm gonna marry them off and once I've
married them off I'll just stop
considering one in C and now I have a
reduced problem I've have for remaining
boys and four remaining girls and
proceeding in this way greedy way for
boys I'm gonna now give boy to his next
choice that remains namely girl a and
I'll marry them off and again now to an
a the
it can be eliminated from consideration
I continue in this way and I wind up
with this set of five marriages ending
with boy 5 married the girl II okay now
if we look at this set of marriages
there's a problem which motivates the
whole stable marriage problem that we're
gonna be examining named examining
namely we've married off boy 1 to his
first choice girls see he should be
happy but she may not be
and we've also married off boy 4 to girl
B now a difficulty here is that if you
look at the preferences girls see
actually is more desirable to boy 4 than
than girl B girls see a boys boy 4 like
somebody else's wife better than his own
and what makes it really bad is that
girls see the other person's wife likes
boy 4 better than her husband each of
them would be better off if they ran off
together they are whether they do or not
they certainly are under tremendous
pressure
it makes the set of marriage is unstable
so they're called a rogue couple when
you have in a set of marriages a boy and
a girl who prefer each other over their
current spouses they are said to be a
rogue couple and a source of instability
so the stable marriage problem is let's
see if we can get everybody married off
and have no rogue couples it'll be a
stable set of marriages now people may
not be happy but it doesn't matter
because they'll never find anybody else
that sanity that is unhappy in the same
way that would be willing to run off
with them and make them happier so it's
stable and it turns out that there
always is a way to find a stable set of
marriages a couple of ways but why don't
we just play with the idea here is a
display of those preferences again and
you can stop the video and fiddle with a
piece of paper and see if you can come
up with a stable set of marriages
between the boys and the girls we used
to do this in class in real time we
would give a 5 different boy
a chart of preferences of girls and we
give the five different girls a chart of
preferences of boys they were not
supposed to tell each other what their
preferences were but the girls were
supposed to be interviewing the boys and
the boys interviewing the girls but
simultaneously in parallel and try to
agree to get married and see whether the
set of marriages that they wound up with
rest' able most of the time they
actually did wind up with a stable set
of marriages but not always just an
amusing exercise and it does illustrate
something about the fact that the
procedures that were going to be going
through define stable marriages work
very nicely if you choose to do them in
parallel anyway there are it turns out
two sets of stable marriages um that we
can find in this particular set of
preferences the simplest one to
understand is all the girls get their
first choice it so happens if you look
at that chart all of the girls have
different first choice boys if we simply
give them their first choice
no girl is gonna be tempted to be part
of a rogue couple cause she's got our
first choice it's absolutely stable but
of course that's a very special
circumstance it would be unusual that
all the girls first choices were
different or likewise it would be
unusual if all the boys first choices
were different but if they were then you
instantly get a stable set of marriages
there's another stable set that's not
quite so obvious and you can check that
um that all of these pairs have no
instability there's no rogue couples in
here when I marry five to a and one to e
um this is a so-called boi optimal set
of marriages it turns out that in this
set of marriages every boy gets the best
possible spouse that he could possibly
get in any set of stable marriages
there's no set of stable marriages in
which boy five gets a more desirable
girl than a there's no set of stable
marriages in which boy one gets a girl
that's more desirable to him than girl
II the sad news is that it's
simultaneously pessimal for the girls
that is each girl is getting their worth
possible spouse among all sets of stable
marriages we'll examine that further in
a minute but let me just point out that
this is more than a puzzle I mean it's
fun and it is it's a nice puzzle but
it's more than a puzzle because the
original case
where it was studied or published first
was in a paper by Gale and Shapley in
1962 you remember that may remember the
name David gale from the subset game
that we played early in the term when we
were practicing with set relations and
what they were dealing was with the
problem of college admissions where
students have rankings of colleges that
they've applied to and their preferences
and colleges have rankings of students
to whom that have applied to them and
we're trying to get matching up between
college offers and student preferences
and in a circumstance where a college
made an offer and a student's sort of
accepted but then later the student got
a another offer from a place they
preferred more and they were changing
their mind and withdrawing with a
acceptances and so on it was making
everybody crazy
the administrators and the students
themselves and the desire was let's get
some stable set of offers on the table
and Gale and Shapley proposed a protocol
to get stable marriages that would apply
to college admissions it turns out
interestingly enough that although Gale
and Shapley are credited with the stable
marriage a solution that we're going to
discuss they they did that because they
were the first to publish it but in fact
it had been discovered and put into
practice at least 20 years earlier by a
national board whose job was to match
interns and hospitals that is graduating
medical students who were about to start
their further clinical training as
interns now called residents in modern
language had to be matched up with
hospitals and the residents had
preferred hospitals that they'd like to
go to and the hospitals had rankings of
residents that met their criteria and
again the issue was how do you assign
residents to hospitals in a stable way
before they had discovered this
stability algorithm it was a mess again
there's a wonderful story in the book by
Gus field and Irving that is an entire
book about the stable marriage problem
published by MIT press I think in 89 and
as a matter of fact I was the editor of
the series in which it appears this
stable marriage problem turns out to
have a lot of structure and they
described a wonderful anecdote and in
their preface about
problems that were happening between the
hospitals and the residents and the
measures that were taken to try to
achieve stability before they discovered
this algorithm another a genuine
computer science application is one that
oh it was described by Tom Leighton who
is a co-author of the text and now the
CEO of the of Akamai a an Internet
infrastructure plumbing company that has
some large number of servers I think
65,000 servers in 2010 around the world
and it basically is providing cached web
pages so that they can respond more
quickly local calls they have a problem
that they get something like sixty two
thousand sixty five thousand servers and
they get I think two hundred billion web
requests a day so the web requests are
kind of acting like the boys and me and
the servers are kind of acting like the
girls or the hospitals and the residents
have based and the the web requests have
preferences based on proximity and speed
of server and the servers have
precedence based on where they're
located and the magnitude of the web
request that they're coming to and the
question is how do you assign web
requests to servers so that things get
done expeditiously and it turns out that
the stable marriage method gave a
satisfactory way to accomplish that kind
of matching it also and in particular
because there's such large numbers
involved that the stable marriage ritual
which were described shortly is very
amenable to being run in parallel
another application that turns out to
come up was in matching Vance partners
when I was teaching this course ten
years ago with a with a co instructor
who was a member of the Indian dance
team she said we could use this because
it turns out that again there boy and
girl partners in the dance and it was
constantly the case that one boy would
like another boys partner better and
vice versa and they would start pairing
up and leaving the other people hanging
and there were bad feelings and it was a
disruptive source of disruption in the
in the society there's a picture of that
Indian dance group
my co-instructor is not actually there
but it gives you a some sense of the
reality of the problem here at MIT and
she told me that it was actually being
used by that group